in case you're there we go way back gy
we go way back you probably go further
back with him then right I I don't know
we we have Sundance memories together I
just flew in from Sundance actually
how's it going over there um it's better
than this carpet in the way you're
treating it
exactly
exactly I over moked my tea how's it
going I'm good I got a lot of stuff but
since it's very hard to talk about this
movie I'm going to ask very important
questions yeah what did Cal think when
you told him you were not only going to
make a movie with Matthew vaugh but um
it was going to be involving a cat and
it was Matthew Von's cat uh well uh
thankfully I had in my contract not to
have too much interaction with the cat
and So Cal went that's fine I'll allow
it he's a very large dog yes yes yes I
know he's upstairs actually oh there we
go so were you more I have a question
for you in a second but were you more
nervous to uh dance with dualipa or uh
wearing the Ivan drag Rocky for haircut
for so long um okay so good question the
the haircut was a fun one um and
definitely out there thank God it didn't
look like that in public so it just it
was just look like very short hair when
when I wasn't on set but doing a dance
move like that with duer yeah you just
it's that's one person I mean you don't
want to drop anyone but you don't want
to drop du leiper either I'd have hordes
of fans off to my off to my head one of
the things is your your performance
what's really cool and I what I read is
that Matthew uh based it on some other
actors and he would give you notes in
terms of on a take saying more Jack
Nicholson or more Bill Murray can you
sort of talk about what what that was
like well I think we referenced that a
little bit in the some of the rehearsal
re read throughs I I think we we were
trying to get it was clear that I had to
be somewhat of a comic relief and and do
some of that stuff so yeah we we would
nerd out on on we we're from about the
same age and we'd nerd out on the same
film references okay the the it's a
Shand you know with a director
completely uh the train fight sequence
is fantastic and the way it's edited the
cross cutting is so well done and it
involves both of you so what was it
that's a very unique set piece so what
was that actually like to film and what
were some of the unique challenges that
both of you had to overcome I think the
challenges really came with the
rehearsing of it it was about learning
each other's um sort of style how each
other moved and then trying to shoot it
with the stunt team so it made sense and
was editable just on small cameras
regular cameras and then transposing
that into real film cameras and working
it that way was a really tricky bit but
you could also kind of hand off to the
other actor so you weren't fighting for
the whole day you'd fight for one setup
and then you go okay cool and and then
Sam would do his stuff or i' do my stuff
and it was kind of nice just to take the
the pressure off and the physical the
physical load yeah they had options
because there's really essentially two
versions of the fight so it it takes the
burden off a little bit I'm going to ask
now the most serious question of the day
uh Henry um what current computer are
you rocking oh my God oh my God you got
me so nervous you got me so nervous with
that computer I'm at Le ey um I've I've
recently just just upgraded everything
to the new it's md5 isn't it um new chip
uh new motherboard uh and 4090 as well
so you a software engineer for God's
sakes I it's
yeah everything's new I I upgraded the
whole thing so uh I I have to also ask I
don't know what he's talking yeah see I
do and uh this goes way back this is
another thing um my La my last thing for
you and I I do have to ask Henry this
and I apologize uh it's a two-parter how
has the training with a sword been going
and what is the status of warmer yeah
this man knows what's up uh the training
is about to begin in Earnest it'll be
it'll be a very long training process
and I'm very excited to get into it um
there's only so much I can tell you at
the moment when to keep everything under
wraps for as long as possible and uh
Warhammer is is progressing very well we
are big things are happening and we are
very
excited